je me suis vu un soir appelé au secours
ma fille avait trois semaines les
personnes est intervenu j'ai traversé un
appartement très très grand soulevées
par le coup sûr à couloir qu'il est à
peu près 15 mètres de long elle criait
au secours il personne est intervenu en
pension que les gens allaient venir
j'avais mon petit garçon qui était
présent et qu'ils ne pouvaient rien
faire il ça a été une fois parmi tant
d'autres est ce que vous vous avez déjà
appelé le lys est oui
à plusieurs reprises suite à une
violente altercation un soir j'ai
quarante reach et d'une amie je m'étais
couché vous m'avez traité ne fait plus
de doute je t'aide ces terrains il était
dans le lit m'attendais quand même comme
un fou vous il s'est débattu il a donné
des coups dans l'allier terrain et pour
faire quitter le domicile ce soir là
j'ai appelé la police qui est arrivée
quand même observer les minutes selon
quand on attend la pluie très très
longue surtout avec deux enfants
mais quand la police est là il ne bouge
plus c'est baie des anges
si des hommes non je ne comprends pas on
a une dispute de coût tout à fait normal
c'est madame qui s'emporte regarder elle
veut m'enlever les enfants je ne
comprends pas pourquoi la paix la police
ce soit c'est pour me nuire
c'est un montage et c'est pas un montage
quand on arrive à appeler la police à
une heure du matin avec deux enfants qui
dorment
ce n'est plus un avantage c'est un appel
au secours
sauf que la police vient vous fait
partir mais derrière vous ne voyez pas
moi j'ai eu de la chance j'ai encore là
les enfants sont là
non c'est c'est pas tout l'alertent
qu'il faut les arrêter ces gens là faut
pas leur laisser encore le pouvoir de
recommencer de recommencer leur commencé
dès les premiers faits il faudrait une
mesure d'éloignement il faudrait que ça
soit beaucoup plus strictes aux
répliques de faire d'un franceries il
faudra zéro tolérance